voyager plus écolo en prenant l'avion
est ce vraiment possible on en parle
avec un régal la diète general d'air
france bonjour théâtrale avec nous
installer vous merci à vous andré patron
du guide du routard qui étaient là un
petit peu avant vous qui nous faisait
part de cette désaffection d'une partie
des voyageurs pour l'avion notamment
exclusivement diéthyle pour les les
week-ends comme ça des virées dans une
capitale européenne partir comme ça en
avion pour 2 3 jours vous aussi vous
voyez ça que tu en avais commencé à
observer des signes en 2019 de nos
clients heures plus tôt les clients
business qui nous disait retravailler
leur politique de voyages je crois que
la crise corrida était l'occasion pour
chacun d'entre nous et pour nos clients
également de se poser un certain nombre
de questions et en particulier de la
façon dont il allait déjà vivre
effectivement différemment et en
particulier voyager et partir
effectivement plus longtemps plus pour
un seul week-end combiné peut-être un
peu plus des tendances qui a une vraie
tendance effectivement qu'est ce que
vous répondez à leurs égales à celles et
ceux qui voient les compagnies aériennes
comme des entreprises par les deux plus
polluantes au monde
gérait que nous soyons évidemment nous
sommes conscients notre impact sur
l'environnement nous ne l'avons jamais
nié nous avons commencé à travailler sur
nos trajectoires de décarbonation depuis
de longues années
aujourd'hui nous le faisons nous
appuyons sur des trajectoires de
décarbonation
appuyer sur la science
nous fixions des objectifs plus court
terme j'irai que nous avons fait des
progrès depuis 2005 nous avons baissé en
valeur absolue nos émissions de co2 de
6% malgré une croissance du trafic pour
la france 2 32% et transparent le groupe
fait partie des bons élèves parce que je
suis tombé sur un classement qui date un
peu de septembre 2020 réalisé par
atmosphère qui est à une organisation
demande à but non lucratif qui a comparé
en euros les 200 plus grandes compagnies
aériennes dans le monde sur leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre air
france n'apparaît pas dans le top 10 et
je me suis dit à l'époque est ce que
vous étiez en retard et c'est peut-être
ce qui explique aujourd'hui sur votre
verdissement ses skis pour expliquer que
vous accélérez y ait aujourd'hui et de
nouvelles ambitions
donc accélération et vitesse
supersonique alors en tout cas après ses
premiers ses débuts de décarbonation on
se fixe aujourd'hui des objectifs plus
court terme le chef nous l'a dit il ya
une urgence donc nous avons évidemment
fixé avec l'ensemble des compagnies
aériennes dans le monde le fait d
décarbonés à 2005 mais ça suffit pas de
bidons remplis l'objectif c'est 2030
2031 jeu précis c'est pas de faire le
pas aux autres 2002 29 et 2030 mais on
démarre baez à 12 % des émissions de co2
par rapport à 2010 neuf ans maintenant
face à lui on va lancer très sérieux
parce que ça paraît ambitieux comme ça
12% c'est ambitieux c'est 30% de moins
par passager kilomètre mais 12% en
valeur absolue avec les hypothèses que
nous avons d'activité intense trafic
exactement alors est-ce que c'est
suffisamment ambitieux en tout cas je
crois que nous utilisons au maximum
l'ensemble des leviers qui sont à notre
disposition
donc vous avez raison on a une flotte
qui fut coton nous avons accéléré le
renouvellement qu'avec l'âge moyen de la
flotte air france mais je crois qu'on a
14 ans pour les moyen-courriers voilà la
moyenne du secteur c'est quoi juste pour
se comparer un petit peu elle est un peu
plus jeune effectivement ça dépend des
compagnies lacc risques aux ide a
bouleversé le sujet puisque les
quadrimoteur sont sortis nous les 340 et
les 3,80 qui volaient ont tous arrêté en
mars 2020 et aujourd'hui on dépense un
milliard par an d'investissements malgré
l'impact financier absolument
gigantesque de la crise sur notre
activité pour renouveler notre flotte
l'objectif c'est 70%
2% de nouvelle génération 2030 avec une
heure aujourd'hui en terme de
renouvellement par an on reçoit que je
ne vous disent pas de bêtises
12 15 ans de 120 airbus de 120
moyen-courriers cette année on va
recevoir 60 d'ici à 2025 et on reçoit je
crois encore 6 350 ont en avoir pris 20
en fin d'année et l'objectif c'est que
près de la moitié de la flotte soit
renouvelée avec ce type d'appareil qui
consomme 20 à 25 % de carburant en moins
parce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont plus
légers c'est qu'ils sont plus âgés 120
l'a350 c'est ça en fait ils sont plus
légers ce sont des matériaux composites
les moteurs sont beaucoup moins
gourmands et finalement le secteur à une
amélioration continue de sa performance
ça suffit pas et donc il faut qu'on
active d'autres leviers
le premier levier c'est vraiment le
renouvellement de la flotte oui c'est
celui qui est disponible il coûte cher
et ont un lien medi 1 milliard par an à
part en comparant qu'on va effectivement
produire tous les ans malgré encore une
fois le trou financier qui a généré
cette crise et qui va nous occuper
également après il ya aussi une rig l
usage des biocarburants oury
incontournable évidemment pour avoir un
avion qui est plus propre qu'est ce
qu'on trouve pardon peu pédagogique est
ce qu'on trouve dans simyo carburant
faut expliquer c'est fabriqué à partir
d'huile usagée alors d'huiles usagées de
déchets forestiers
ce qui est important c'est que les
carburants durables que l'aviation peu
utilisé dans la réglementation
européenne par exemple sont des
carburants de deuxième génération donc
ce n'est pas forcément ce que vous allez
mettre dans votre voiture ou dans un
camion qui ne sont pas en compétition
avec l'alimentation et l'idée c'est que
sur l'ensemble de leur cycle de vie on
n'aimait 80 % de co2 en moins ça veut
dire que finalement sur l'ensemble de
cycle de vie d'une huile végétale la
croissance de la plante la croissance
des déchets fait que vous économisez 80%
effectivement de co2 en moins
c'est un gros le vieux sang c'est un
énorme levier ça voudrait dire qu'il
faut pour réduire l'empreinte carbone du
transport aérien ça deviendra le premier
levier aujourd'hui on en incorpore que
seulement 1% c'est le mandat que
l'incorporation français objectif 10 %
en 2030 notre objectif déportant la
réglementation c'est 5% mais encore vite
si vraiment c'est pour deux raisons
parce que la première raison c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas disponibles et
l'enfant que deux banques de
biocarburants on manque de carburants
durables donc aujourd'hui de
biocarburants il faut vraiment que les
énergéticiens passe la démultipliée en
dira toute l'énergie d'aller plus et
c'est ce que nous disons à total énergie
à l'ensemble des énergéticiens ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est qu'entre le
mandat réglementaire français et nos
clients business qui pour réduire leur
scope 3 donc essentiellement pour
beaucoup d'entreprises les voyages leurs
collaborateurs il nous demande d'acheter
du carburant durable et nous n'en avons
pas assez pour répondre à l'ensemble de
la demande et vous le voyez nous
accélérons et entre pour atteindre plus
de 10% à 2030 si on veut suivre une
trajectoire de décarbonation qui sera
validée par sbt avoue saï saï saï 11 bis
target de l'organisme qui peut valider
que notre décarbonation a du sens et
ensuite ça va monter très fort puisque
on estime qu'aujourd'hui il faudra plus
de 60 % de carburant durable à l'horizon
2050 carburants durables qui émettent
beaucoup moins de co2 mais qui coûta
denguele beaucoup plus cher diaz sur
coup ils font parler d'un surcoût par
rapport au kérosène et de combien
aujourd'hui entre 4 et 8 fois plus cher
que le kérosène voilà sachant que j'ai
oublié de dire mais c'est important la
limite du truc aujourd'hui c'est la
limite puisqu'on on en produit peu et
donc il faut vraiment que le cercle
vertueux s'enclenche une industrie une
filière en fait oui je crois que là le
signal de la demande est là parce qu'il
ya des règlementations comme fit sofisti
five en europe qui impose des seuils que
les compagnies vont au delà nous mêmes
nous annonçons que nous allons au delà
et donc effectivement il faut que les
volumes génère une baisse du prix voilà
parce que derrière c'est le client qui
paye j'imagine alors est-ce qu'il sera
transparent vous avez augmenté
d'ailleurs déjà volé prix de vos billets
vacanciers à notre client ou liée aux
biocarburants piqué que sur leurs
billets il verrait de manière très
transparente
l'effet des mandats d'incorporation donc
quelques euros aujourd'hui ces quelques
euros et nous espérons que une
production de plus de volume permettra
de contenir ces surcoûts mais bien sûr
que voyager aura un coût 10 ferrand à
l'avenir ouais la question à savoir si
les clients seront prêtes à payer
toujours plus cher même pour voyager
écolo et finalement si vous voyagez
durable et vert sera pas réservée à une
élite quelques parents à l'objectif et
l'ambition effet que je me lève tous les
matins c'est effectivement de réussir à
avoir un transport aérien qui soit pas
contraire à notre vision effectivement
de d'une trajectoire de décarbonation et
qu'ils soient pas réservés comme dans
les années 60 a à quelques happy few aux
états unis on rigole les compagnies
aériennes bénéficient carrément de
crédit d'impôt pour inciter à utiliser
justement ces biocarburants vous
amérique la france en face se parler ça
fait partie des discussions que nous
avons avec la france et avec l'europe
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que ces
régulations ces réglementations si elles
ont lieu en france alors qu'on est un
transport aérien hyper concurrentiel et
internationale ça relativement peu de
chansons qu'il faut a minima que la
réglementation soit européenne voire
mondiale mais oui nous pensons que des
incentive candidats existent au niveau
fédéral aux états unis mais également au
niveau local aujourd'hui quand vous
cherchez du biocarburant vous avez
souvent le chercher à san francisco et
los angeles parce qu'il est seulement
10% plus cher que du carburant classique
et pourquoi vieux parce qu'entre les
incentive de l'état fédéral et de l'état
local on arrive effectivement à des prix
qui sont un peu différentes qu'on peut
trouver en europe aujourd'hui dans les
leviers mme rigal pour réduire
l'empreinte carbone du transport aérien
aussi l'écho pilotage que j'ai découvert
d'ailleurs en préparant les missions
c'est une façon d'être plus vertueux en
quoi ça consiste
est-ce que c'est pas malgré tout aussi
un peu gadget on a vraiment des chiffres
pour montrer l'impact réel significatif
sur les émissions de co2 parce que on
roule pas trop vite quand on est au sol
je sais pas ou alors aujourd'hui c'est
pas le premier levier d'ailleurs je vous
en ai pas parlé comme premier levier
aujourd'hui on estime que ces 3 % de
baisse des émissions parce
qu'effectivement va rouler sur un seul
moteur quand on est sur le sur le
taxiway on va choisir avec
l'intelligence artificielle avec un sa
tante de logiciels des trajectoires qui
optimise la consommation de carburant
donc c'est pas le premier levier mais on
va chercher tous les % et comme on
lisait il faut activer tous les leviers
c'est également un formidable facteur
d'engagement pour nos pilotes qui sont
extrêmement motivés pour effectivement
réussir un peu quand on va essayer en
voiture de consommer le moins possible
et ne pas faire un plein de kérosène
aussi de voler en ayant temps plein que
l'avion soit pas rempli un serment le
kérosène si y'a pas besoin à 100%
les co pilotage c'est de faire en sorte
d'en porter
le minimum de carburant en toute
sécurité il faut en permanence voir le
contexte du vol aéroports les aéroport
de déroutement possible etc et à voir
les trajectoires et on a de plus en plus
d'outils avec le wifi on peut connaître
effectivement de plus en plus finement
les impacts des différentes trajectoires
est calculé en permanence ce que sera la
consommation avec telle ou telle
trajectoire dont la solution ultime pour
voyager vers et ne pas émettre de co2
c'est l'avion hydrogène avions zéro
émission mais là c'est pas pour tout de
suite et pas avant 2035 c'est pas avant
35 c'est ce que nous dit airbus fabrique
pas d'avion donc je pense le jour un
avion d carbone existe on sera ravi d'en
acheter comme beaucoup de compagnies
aériennes et il faut avoir en tête
également que l'avion hydrogène comme
l'avion électrique répondent à des
distances qui sont limitées arbus
annonce 3500 km par exemple pour les
avions hydrogène or une compagnie comme
air france l'essentiel de ses émissions
ces deux longs courriers donc je dirais
que les carburants durables de ce point
de vue sont absolument essentielles et
également les gains d'efficacité des
moteurs et des avions plus légers allez
merci beaucoup à une rigueur la dir est
général d'air france merci alors deux
[Musique]